today's new member of the day is Peter
Leon Bruno Peter thank you for being a
member really appreciate your support
January was an incredible month for new
members February is not as good but
still going pretty well and Peter is one
of the great folks who has signed up at
WWJ Ann pakman.com somebody who's been
with us for years is Dan Langdon he's
today's a Hall of Fame longtime
sustaining member of the day with us
almost 5 years now
Peter and Dan thank you join them save
40% using the coupon code this is 2020
if you like this show membership gives
you access to the bonus show which is
every single day it's an additional show
just for our subscribers check it out at
WWE at medCom ok some interesting posts
that appeared on the david pakman show
subreddit which is quickly hurdling
towards 10,000 participants at david
pakman.com slash reddit it is a place to
hang out and talk about politics with
other viewers david pakman.com slash
reddit noticed a very interesting post
this has sort of come up before question
2 Pakman and other Zen lefties amaya Zen
lefty I don't know how do you keep your
cool when I see clearly racist people
getting away with it I get angry when I
see policy based on ignorance championed
I get depressed and so on how do you
disconnect and stop it affecting your
emotions and ultimately your life
outlook with negativity two things one
is more sad than advice really one thing
that keeps me calm is that I'm very
desensitized to political insanity
because I've been doing the show for so
long I realize when I'm talking to other
people and it comes up that as as for
example we're talking about later today
a Republican said he would drown his
kids if they were gay that's horrible
and stunning and absolutely ridiculous
that anybody would say that but I
noticed that I don't react in the same
visceral way that people who don't
follow this stuff all the time do so
part of my quote is n lefty ISM and not
being bothered by stuff is that I'm
desensitized to it because I've been
doing this for the for so long I don't
think that's good the other thing that I
do think anybody can do and is
is you've got to have set times to sort
of detox from news and politics for me
it's mostly the weekends I don't do from
the time we're done with a Friday show
until I start prepping the Monday show
typically late late later Sunday I not
only don't do politically related
writing for the show I try to not even
watch politics and my mom will say did
you see what happened with such-and-such
and I'll say mom I I didn't because I'm
not doing the show right now and I'm
deliberately sort of detoxing from that
so I think that's another really
important thing to do to kind of keep
perspective and remain a little more Zen
to the extent that it's possible given
how crazy things actually are also from
the David Pakman show subreddit a viewer
pointing out that Donald Trump already
has a propaganda news show a lot of
people don't realize this but one of the
Trump sons wives I think this is Eric
Trump's wife maybe is this Larry from
Larry Trump Eric Trump's wife this is
Larry Trump Larry Trump hosts some kind
of a I don't know what the name of it is
but it's like a Trump TV thing Trump
pence television and she does something
called a real news update and it is
total propaganda and it exists so for
people who are unsure what a trump state
sponsored propaganda network would look
like it would look a lot like what Larry
Trump is already doing for them and I
sort of encourage you to check it out
just to know that it's going on but at
the same time don't watch too much of it
because it is complete and utter garbage
but thanks for pointing it out in any
case join the discussion at david
pakman.com slash read it the subreddit
growing very very quickly one of the
biggest progressive media subreddits
around much bigger than the subreddits
of other progressive shows and some
pretty good conversation happening there
on a daily basis